now grab I get him on top of a car
his head is right here this [ __ ]
Mike my [ __ ] exciting episode here
and hotboxing Evan Brittany Mike Tyson
we got our main man here right here mr.
Michael Rapaport hell yeah
glad to be here good to have you yeah
it's a it's it's it's literally a
winning where when when it comes to Mike
Tyson mom tell us man where you we've
actually fun huh yeah
all right I'm from Manhattan yeah I grew
up in Manhattan born and raised in
Manhattan my whole life um you know grew
up in the city playing ball that was my
thing playing really oh yeah I loved and
then and then you know when I was 12 I
met my friend my best friend who's from
Howard houses I told you about yeah yeah
how is my my neighborhood yeah grounds
that said the PA le learn the box did
yeah so in 1983 and you know what
remember was like I mean you were
probably 15 16 I used to go out to
Brownsville I was 12 12 year old white
dude and I'd go play ball and Howard to
play for the Brownsville jets with Jocko
and they said and we'll be free without
that world without them well I was out
there I Williams you're the eyes of my
guy a wolf and those guys guys that do
you hammer and all these guys from
Howard and but I was a kid I was a
[ __ ] you know 12 and you know Mike
knows what it was like I did but I
wasn't involved in I was a kid that's
what I wanted to say how did you get out
there cuz if any white guy out there
he's a dangerous person what were you
doing
you know we out there first so I wasn't
in when you're 12 12 years old and like
I knew everybody in Howard so I know
shred is the [ __ ] trip when you think
think about it and it just when the trip
you know this it was it was crazy
because at that time I remember in
Spring Break of 83 I was out there
playing ball my friends and there would
be gunshots and I would literally like
oh [ __ ]
and my friends would laugh because they
were so accustomed to it and when I look
back and you think about in America and
Brooklyn the fact that little kids would
be get accustomed and gunshots like
they're not I remember you know when you
started when I started hearing your name
Brownsville Mike Tyson from Brownsville
Kid Dynamite and Sports Illustrated and
seeing you on ESPN like you know there's
so much people that came from
Brownsville from the ballplayers will be
free to - pearl - you know Jimmy Smith's
- Otis Otis Wilson of that the Bears and
this little this little [ __ ]
neighborhood and you know and for me
being around that at that time I was
exposed to so much [ __ ] and it's a good
thing you know because it opened my eyes
and made me realize it's not just the
East Side of Manhattan and so is it was
a dope up ring but it was all basketball
and hip-hop and chasing girls you know
like I wasn't a treatment for the
dangerous place dangerous [ __ ] place
dangerous [ __ ] place but I was always
you know looked after and [ __ ] cuz I was
in a charm a god you think I don't care
what color you they got you you and they
got you got you know word date they had
me and like [ __ ] were like yo
this is our guy no [ __ ] once they
say that you good you end this up man
right yeah yeah so that's what I grew up
in New York City and and and you know is
all I had hoop dreams I wanted to be an
NBA player I wanted to be a professional
basketball player but I my hoop dreams
turn into you know hoop nightmares how
did you flip oh cause death what's been
your relationship with hip-hop hanging
around those guys and browns yeah stuff
and the radio you know and
in the radio like hip-hop was you know
my father worked at he was the general
manager of WK to you disco 92 with Paco
and Roscoe and and and before this was a
the first station in New York City to
play disco and before they play disco
they played mellow rock this is like 77
78 79 and then 79 he came home and he
said you know stations going to disc on
nine he just was telling me about it he
started playing all disco in the station
went from the bottom of the ratings to
the top but that same year he brought
home a record he brought him a
promotional copy of rapper's delight' by
a Sugar Hill Gang and he said this is
rap music it's gonna be a real thing and
[ __ ] I [ __ ] would get all the records
and then being out in the streets
playing ball and listening to BLS and
kiss and [ __ ] like that I just wasn't
ready ki Crocker breaking sheet rock
afraid you better learn yeah and then
that [ __ ] was just you know it's just
around me so it was just so organic
thing and I fell in love with hip-hop
the music and then later on you know
like going to the clubs in the Latin
Quarter is Latin Quarter the tunnel yeah
but black quarters in Union Square and
all that [ __ ] was [ __ ] was it on you
in 14 years where my uncle met with the
matter who were you going here before
you were Mike Tyson where you going into
Rob [ __ ] and I never listen this is the
deal right
I had just stopped doing the robbing
stuff I just met customer I was starting
to hang out in the clubs again and stuff
just like 86 no this is like what what
what is it 81 ok ok I will go back and
visit and stuff and man in the clubs was
just crazy they're in a misfit zoning
the missus went to hip hop's if he
wasn't admit that you wouldn't be there
it was just a place that people said you
were that the hip-hop placement while me
but be careful in there it was wild in
the clubs you know you would see you I
saw this with my own eyes in 86 in Union
Square girls get their [ __ ] earring
snatch you know dudes getting night and
and you you know I mean in a club like
I'm like and I'm like open Rob
snatching change you know take him on
[ __ ] jackets and and and it was it
was in the club I was in Latin quarters
I I never forgot this
it was either 86 or 87 in in land
quarters were infamously Plaxico Burress
people would go out the Latin Quarter
than any more guy but Latin quarters
it's like a place that I guess it was
around in the 50s it's been around but I
remember being in land quarters standing
next to the late
Scott lorac from bdp I see my favorite
yeah yes and and he asked me to come to
the thing maybe around man I think when
they come to the video video any no
wasn't anything I was just - no I know
anything about videos affected I ain't
know it was a but there and and and I
there was a fight broker there's always
fights but I remember it was just a
wintertime I'm Skyler rock is right here
and I were like leaning on the thing
there's a fight you're not really paying
attention because they would get broken
up and it'd be little skirmishes but
this was a big fight that was happening
over there and these are grown men I'm
sixteen nine you know they didn't serve
the reason why they let kids in is cuz
they didn't serve alcohol at the bar I
realized this later so so uh uh dude
reaches into his his his uh his I think
it was like a sheepskin or as a bubble
goose and pulls out a sword in the club
not a little [ __ ] box cutter or sword
at it yo I ran down the stairs and and
and to leave probably right where
Plaxico Burress shot himself and then a
somebody else from behind me
breaks a bottle over somebody in the
glass jars on me and I'm like fine I'm
going to get my jacket from the jacket
coat I say [ __ ] my jacket I go down the
stairs and I swear this is all true and
you there was a glass window and and a
dad while I'm going down the stairs to
the glass window I see a guy I see this
oh oh
Times Square I mean in Union like in
times crisis in like 11
and I go into the corner me and this
girl we're just like waiting for this
[ __ ] to stop and then it just stopped
got my jacket and a couple weeks later I
was back Atlanta corners like it was
like it was nothing but it takes to see
that [ __ ] when you think about like the
danger that was going on when you're 16
17 you're so [ __ ] dumb and I wasn't a
tough guy was a round tough guy yeah but
listen could take something that
adrenaline is addicting you want to go
back to that Club beautiful chick she
never seen before them hot latino
chillin out and my god what the first
time I saw Mike Tyson you hadn't won the
Bell yet you had been on the cover of
kid dying kid kid Kid Dynamite you had
been the cover of Sports Illustrated but
I remember I saw you walking down the
deuce in a red feel odd jumpsuit and you
I guess you had gotten cut sparring and
you had a band-aid and you were walking
with a chick and you had a rope on and
you were walking it was that Brownsville
walk see that yeah yeah but you were
Mike Tyson but I'm like you you weren't
like famous famous but you'd like a few
new boxing and that I remember you got
walked past you and I was with my friend
Gerald who's from Browns and was like oh
[ __ ] there's Ike Tyson and we just said
what's up Mike and you you were holding
a girl's hand you had the rope on and
and you're you're you're feel a velour
[ __ ] and I was the sight so dude I never
and it was when the deuce was still the
do it was what listen listen I first
came to the Doosan was 1977 those 11
years old I'm on the deuce ready I'm
going in with pickpocket and so um when
I get this so you sound like you never
believe me unless you're thousands of
people walking around and you have
people coming up to you and after
cocaine got that we got that [ __ ] on
the side got that [ __ ] got hoes got
pizza okay and people overwhelmingly
intoxicated right and then you're
getting your friends a little picking
pockets and stuff some people we um some
people we have to rob we have bad to get
the rob one of the goddamn mom
ha ha ha ha the perverts and stuff the
guys don't want you to sucks wanna suck
your dick and [ __ ] so we set them up and
Robin and say we let them suck I think
Oh
and we rob them yes daddy gov it was
crazy so noisy
dad it was this is right I mean it's a
it's like some straight-up taxi driver
[ __ ] like this is like it was like it
was you know pornos and movies and pimps
and like it wasn't that's not a set
that's a real [ __ ] and if you [ __ ] up
you can die yeah he left up there well
my brother and I where we were born in
New York City lived in Brooklyn till I
was 10 then my mom moved us out here but
we were talking about you know and that
was the early 90s how much cleaner it
was Giuliani but it was still a good job
raising cuz cuz you're a little older
than me and and you're a New Yorker cuz
people go back and forth this you know
that's like uh uh like some people say
the old New York I'm like yo the way we
described that it's cool to reminisce
about it but that [ __ ] wasn't dope like
you listen my kids did take my kids here
right well never want it to be like that
again you know like let alone your kids
I guess in a dope you feel safe right
feel safe I would never do so because I
took my careful baby I come I'm I can't
bring you here baby I couldn't be my
kids here no why would you bring your
kids in like it's a [ __ ] for no weed
coke does scumbags [ __ ] robbers the
lowest of the lows of the city name I
came from different states if the
seasons so dirty was so [ __ ] dirty at
all so crazy it was a [ __ ] line very
slimy people back so yeah so that's
about New York is I mean [ __ ] it's it's
change it's changed but it's good it's
good change is good you know for you
know there's always pros and cons all
that [ __ ] yeah so how'd you get into
acting then I got into acting cuz I
wanted to be a basketball player I knew
when I was about 17 I wasn't even gonna
come close to being a basketball player
I got kicked out of school every single
year just for talking [ __ ] I wasn't no
nobody wasn't burning buildings and
starting fires I just was disruptive
disruptive behavior did your mother take
you to the doctor get you medicine stuff
they wanted to give me medicine in the
third grade that to me
Dean and all that yeah it's crazy yeah
[ __ ] maniac that's why I turned up
[ __ ] up my mom my father didn't let me
get on the [ __ ] I dropped the mind yes I
probably could have used a little
[ __ ] mood stabilizer but they date at
the time back then back then yeah
what weird aunt would they had you'll
cuz you were just were you were you wild
physically wild emotionally like why
didn't love mostly physically cried the
drop of the dime attack the teacher all
that crazy [ __ ] those guys right Rob did
you snatcher personally the [ __ ]
class running up the classroom where do
you think you're going with a purse I'm
gonna spend the money I know guys come
back to school and I come back to school
to copy their ass my ass
this is in Brooklyn yes yes oh I uh I
was just disruptive but I would have
been in the client you know they called
it the retorted class yesterday and you
know the fucked-up thing is we were just
in there no they never really but I'm
really glad I mean it wasn't [ __ ]
special ed together and in Ginny in
junior high school Portland school Ella
Elementary yeah you would Riddick yes
Jesus [ __ ] nice crazy school explain
Brownsville is in terms of like defected
to heavyweight champions at the same
time from the same era came out of
explain that the size of it listen right
it's a trip it's not a big is not big
but it's over [ __ ] crowded over pop
projects just prop projects right and we
have people on top of one another
constantly it's pressure on top of
another and every now and then it's
tough to blow and people just start
shooting and stuff rob and we have riots
it's just really crazy small [ __ ]
area
shooting cops cops shooting us yeah it's
you know it's [ __ ] up because they
can't they can't fix Brownsville unless
they there's too many projects listen up
they're not gonna gentrify brown brown I
always said that that's not that's the
only part of Brooklyn that's not gonna
get that pretty to go fix it up they may
put a few trees there but they're not
gonna fix it up
make condominiums out of the projects is
this too much yeah you know with it
really it was a waif is the weight feel
before was a brown the browns really
just a waste field where they put the
garbage at then they've turned in some
guy brown brown bought it oh they called
the Brownsville and cleaned it up with
no more garbage dump and Brownsville
East New York I saw it like you if you
look at the beginning of Goodfellas like
like there was like Italians yeah my
grandmother look grew up in East New
York I'm God he's from Brownsville right
so I I mean I don't know how the [ __ ]
that should happen but it's it's of I
don't know man it's it's a [ __ ] up it
so it so it's a [ __ ] up [ __ ] up
situation out there because now that
they're trying to you know give people
better opportunities in Brooklyn I don't
know how the [ __ ] they're gonna fix it
I'm a Joe Pepitone of the B got busted
in Browns yeah yeah yeah and a day yeah
yeah yeah Joe Pepitone that's crazy so
yeah so I so I was a [ __ ] talker as far
as going back to the AK I was a [ __ ]
talk I had a big mouth funny and always
loved comedy and I loved Eddie Murphy
like I wanted but I didn't want to be a
comedian I wanted to be Eddie Murphy
everybody did back then man he was the
man oh yeah have no idea it was just the
[ __ ] man he he's the first guy then I
realized I wanted rolled voice I've been
to this house before I was always living
in our apartment condos and stuff in the
city right and then I went over this
house I saw his master's property it's
called the [ __ ] in Jersey yeah right
bubble Hill where every was and that's
that's what I want I don't want to con
them only live in a house that's dope
dude though that was like one of the
first like party like you guys used to
party your help man didn't we make what
do you remember about that [ __ ]
specifically Eddy's crib you have crazy
parties he was know like he was he was
doing that [ __ ] before it was like but
he didn't drink her what he liked we had
a bunch of girls about this time my life
I was really just on the scene a little
bit shy and stuff but he had them all he
had them all everybody yes I even
married listen I'm married to a good at
men she was party in there with me one
time I married her stuff Wow she's my
wife
out there yeah but she couldn't cook she
had a boyfriend up boy everyone let it
come to Eddie's party wait that the
marriage not Robin
no [ __ ] way forty no after that so
yeah so I mean it's so but I'd like that
he was like the guy I wanted to be I
loved movies and when I realized you
know I wasn't gonna be a basketball
player I started doing comedy when I was
19 this is 1989 and then when I started
doing come I was okay
I was I was okay I could talk [ __ ] I
could [ __ ] around but then the first
time I ever read a scene like like sides
from a scene like a scene like it came
more natural than ever playing
basketball then doing comedy and I was
like this is what I'm gonna do like I
knew what was the it it was you know
there was a show for HBO that never went
but but reading the sides like it was
like literally like a fish to water like
basketball never came as easy yeah
nothing nothing ever came as easy like I
was like I'm gonna do this and and and
and IA just was I was like a comfort
doing it and and then I fortunately got
good brakes I got good brakes because I
I know I could do it but then it's about
the opportunities and you know and if
you know and I got I got a good break
when I was young and and you know been
rockin ever since and love doing it
still and you know like I love I don't
like the business of it nobody likes the
business of anything man the objective
is him the one in you to lose yeah the
business is [ __ ] it's show business
it should be called business show cuz
cuz we're without the business there's
no [ __ ] show but the actual doing of
it to doing it and and and and the
performing and the artistry of it like I
still get elation from doing it and I
love doing it it's awesome man you've
always been one of my favorite
personalities - I remember listen don't
you remember that I had a fight one day
I don't know where with the fight in
Tennessee I think jay-z and them have
some shooting you as hosting for them
yeah yeah when you fought the [ __ ]
what was the boo they would dip the
black snake black [ __ ] you mean
the black rhino the black rhino and and
jay-z was ho doing a show for it for
Showtime a concert this is like 2001
2002 something like that and and and it
was gonna be a concert then we were
gonna go right to the fight and I was I
was hosting it with jay-z's Rockefeller
Dame - beanie sigel freeway and all him
and I was the host and I was like the
liaison to get from you know I got Jay
on stage and then afterwards like all
right we're heading right over to the to
the fight we had a police escort and
it's my first time seeing notice - my
second time seeing him like maybe it's
the first time seen a Mike Tyson fight
was the McNeeley fight after this or
before - flooded this is before McNeely
after it okay so I was at the McNeely
fight so I go to these [ __ ] 87 second
fights you know where you're all height
to [ __ ] and it's like it's over before
you know so so we do the show we get a
police escort over to the arena I sit
right and [ __ ] literally where my
hands are on the ring like literally
ringside like I'm like this mic comes
out buh-buh-buh-buh-buh the whole
thing's [ __ ] over it wasn't even as
long as a jay-z song and it was like I
go to see these [ __ ] fights and you
know but I got to see Mike fight and and
you knows you know you look back on it
it's the [ __ ] it was it was a
dope-ass a dope-ass don't pass time I
don't pass memory to have that you know
in the history of it especially it also
being a boxing fan like i grew up such a
fan of boxing and and and and such a fan
of the ABC fights such a fan of all that
stuff Saturday fight yeah and and you
know and then like when the guys they
were like in the morning afternoon time
you didn't even like it was like you
come on and and you you know you're your
other guy like I remember watching Mark
breelan and air and Pryor boom boom like
that fight where that cop that was on on
on on ABC fine Sookie that was during
the day fight - they both were fight
banging 15 rounds there bang that's the
best one of the reason they change it to
12 rounds go most of the death happens
after the 12th round
around 40 around but the fights were big
so like you know being around it and my
father loved fight fighting and I used
to go to the fights but every fight that
I've gone to every boxing match that
I've gone to live has been a whack fight
if it was a Mike's fight I seen a couple
of [ __ ] um fight so my man my man
from Philly Bernard Hopkins live always
bad fights or boring fights I've never
been to a like I've never been to a
fight fight like even like the Riddick
the Riddick Holyfield fights like I was
never at good fight i watch them on TV
but I've never seen like a great boxing
match alive man [ __ ] [ __ ] Chavez with
the Beast back in the day it's cool you
see the chair [ __ ]
Aaron Pryor yeah look at the grave god
we will kill you um I saw him when they
hit this guy in the liver the liver the
spleen there boom the guy started just
[ __ ] on himself going to fight yeah
Buster stool like just as a fan forget
the business of it cuz I'm gay you know
I like you're such a fan or you were I
don't know if you still are as much and
you know boxing so well but just as a
fan to the fan in you are you sad at the
state of boxing today just just as a fan
you know what this is what I have to say
I'm sad at the state of the promotion of
boxing there's a couple of good friends
um there's some arrows fences out there
this Giovanni Davis and Plus you know
they got the great [ __ ] um liam
lomachenko AHA right those guys should
be put up on promoted more people should
know they are these guys are really
splendid fighters and they will make
people go back and see boxes and people
knew who they were
do you think that do you think that the
fact that like um the clips go guys and
and and and Linux started it because he
was extra big but do you think that
these guys being like 6 9
Rock'em Sock'em robot [ __ ] has taken
away from the heavyweight
did the heavyweight division because
like in your prime your 220
yeah your 510 217 these guys I mean
whether you could beat them or not it's
just like why is it six foot nine 280
pound guy fighting a 217 pound and this
is the heavy weight this is [ __ ] like
like to me it's like wouldn't like when
you're watching to six foot nine guys
just boom boom boom they could barely
[ __ ] move uh whether they did good on
that Klitschko deal or not
what it does not interest like Ali was
six three to twenty Earnie Shavers has
weren't big guys like I feel like there
should be a loose vision for that weight
like between 200 to 40 no this is the
reason you can't do that know why it's
interesting because they're still guys
that 200 pounds that Kanaka guys is 260
but what if you get in the Wondrich I
can't knock the best 260 guy out it
depends it depends on the fighter
depending on the world the determination
of the fight scene just being a a big
fighter it doesn't mean anything and
you've seen that these things you big as
good but the guys will and determination
he can beat you I know but I'm saying
like even it like I would like but but
as a division like the best of the best
is there's a certain thing but like I'm
saying like you know like the as a whole
the heavyweight division you notice the
[ __ ] that you should be the the
biggest star in the world whoever it was
if it was you if it was Buster Douglas
it was Ali Ken Norton going back that
was the guy and now it's like who's a
heavyweight champion it so it's Tyson
Fury D aren't they oh wait what - [ __ ]
weak yeah it's just eventually in time
they don't have to take it I get that
together and all these guys on have to
fight one day I guess I hope so
downright yeah I just miss I just miss
it I miss it cuz you know I like UFC but
I just missed though that golden era of
it should be one champion and he should
be a fifth I should be she won chairman
he fights everybody from every division
for me his organization
yeah yeah I miss it because I love it
like you know I love the the sport I
love the sport and I have such
admiration for it and it's just not the
same you know whatever
no man it's interesting [ __ ] though you
know what you know what I think is dope
Mike is that I call myself the New
Balance King but the fact that you [ __ ]
with that New Balance dad sneakers 17
size size is 14 1440 Mike I it's it's
Larry David Bernie Sanders Woody Allen
every other every other old Jew and Mike
Tyson's
much my feet of luck
you got these are the best it's often
you need a bath bro can't live without
those 1440 yeah Jesus Christ [ __ ] Mike
I'm can you hook up hook up yes cuz I
was like Mike Mike is rocking the dad
shoes now like I love that about that I
love that about my family I can't wear
any of the shoes I can't wear flat shoes
I can't wear any of that fly [ __ ]
anything I used to fight without my
socks on stuff just barefoot I got my um
my feet cut off [ __ ] what happens
when they get black and hard on the
couch or something like that out yet
but my toes blew up looking at toenails
blue you got [ __ ] up feet Mike yeah my
feet will scare you man my feet are like
Eagles my toenails many stitches okay
what else
Mike you [ __ ] with the housewives at
[ __ ] I love the housewife
where are you at right now I'm your
Bravo [ __ ] listen to no one I do I must
get on with the Love & Hip Hop but the
housewives really with the Atlanta
housewives I like the Real Housewives of
Atlanta yeah like they're bummed out
right oh yeah trip man and and real love
and hip hop it I'm just like wow there
is no [ __ ] there's no shame in the
game I love and hip hop and and the
house ours like they just they just they
just go like I guess you get comfortable
around the camera cuz some people say
that shit's fake I'm like that ain't
[ __ ] real
that listen they may tell them you got
to spice it up a little make a little
bit more violent something get more
drunk well I think they say why don't go
go talk to her about that thing that
really bothers you because you Meryl
Streep and and Marlon Brando on their
best day they weren't as good as these
watch it all [ __ ] now what the
reruns could be caught them I'm glad you
guys are you [ __ ] with that cuz I'm all
about it myself when I was young I might
win out one of the girls what did you
some of those you know some of those
Housewives right you I respected but
when you watch it because I do like to
me they're like stars it's like so proud
it starts to me to know [ __ ] dude the
[ __ ] hip-hop chicks and the guys I'm
hit all those guys it's entertainment to
me it's like soap opera for men and [ __ ]
completely I love it with no shame in my
real men watch Real Housewives oh oh
listen my man Joe for one [ __ ] up and
locked up in Jersey guys [ __ ] up yeah
yeah yeah juicy Joe yeah we gotta get
you out of this freak show three years
ago three [ __ ] juicy Joe you know
what Mike what do you think of this uh
this this Empire kid that Jesse Soleil
[ __ ]
Oh does he's smaller small a small and
hot from what perspective I could look
at from the woman to go passion and say
hey listen II still even being and what
he did
yeah I want you Mike I just want your
instinct on that like what the [ __ ] is
this guy I'm it's not like econ in a
lecture chair yeah but listen no I think
what was the purpose of doing it he
wanted people to love you so sorry for
you and sympathize with you and get you
jobs yes get you to [ __ ] other
[ __ ] now that they know that
just are your biggest fame is [ __ ] him
up the fame [ __ ] it like he know the
attention wasn't enough he wanted more
he wanted to be a freedom fighter
yeah listen yeah no he just want to be a
[ __ ] held up high right that's
you like hearing it cuz I think it was
all I can he said I'm the black Tupac I
want to be looked at like somebody's for
the culture about the people and all
that guy to forgive the guy beside the
thing is I'm not being dissed no he's a
new young actor he's not like some big I
mean it's no disrespect he's like he's
an up-and-coming actor that's it that's
it man what he did set people back I
agree you know man I'm nothing could be
from a black perspective to by me
talking about people being beat down
it's dangerous fondling yeah you shoulda
did that and listen I'm I'm no one to
judge members god damn yeah I think you
do it you wouldn't the [ __ ] are you
doing what the [ __ ] are you doing dude
like dude do something that sort of
cherry juice do something what the [ __ ]
are you doing
yeah wait he's gonna go a hole that he's
clear everything he wants when you go to
prison you know I mean he's clean
yeah problems if he goes he's not gonna
go to prison he probably do jail like
for three months well isn't he claiming
like mental illness he's gonna explain
so he explained the infliction the
exploit he being gay now he's gonna
exploit the mental helm the member is he
talking that [ __ ] that's what he's
saying
that's what his out is fan I think yo
Mike this is one question I'm gonna ask
straight up man I know you don't like to
talk about this I love talking about
everything now but when you just simple
as this when you were in prison did you
ever have to shoot joints that's a
question I wanted like did you ever
actually shoot joints cuz there's all
these rumors and like for you know like
Street fables but what did you ever have
to put hands on somebody when you were
locked down
um just one time one family one
somebody trot like wanted to shoot joint
or you had like like how does that work
with you at that time to my fifth a nice
whoa nobody's hit him boom that's it
yeah why would anyone want like they
were talking out of pocket to you or
just around the in in you you know what
I mean no we would lock down for a long
time and he was just send them with
irritable he said Sunday's when overhead
got you
alright so it wasn't like he wanted to
school you know we're going outside
knock down we couldn't get out we're
going to the gym use lockdown for my gut
stabbed through the woods lockdown and I
was just upset Ghana terrible all right
all right cuz you know like you know
like in Penitentiary in these you know
these movies act like somebody would
want to actually shoot joint on him no I
don't have to shoot join happen now all
right and then my second question Mike I
know you've talked about this and he's
made a return are you knew him back in
the days and you probably reconnected
with him dapper dan that's all he's
looking good too man you couldn't do
with him
no I haven't talked somebody I'm gonna
get him on here trying to get him on
this [ __ ] iPod here Mike I could
connect you yeah I could yeah I won't do
that listen I used to always get my
clothes from dapper Dan's back in the
eighties right and listen this is what
happened that's not rented a stupid
[ __ ] mid screen right I had went
to that but then earlier that day like
12 or 11 o'clock that afternoon I'm
morning and I fitted for some clothes
and so we were supposed to come later
but we hung out we probably drinking and
we were in DC so we drove all the way
back and so we came back for this cold
up there and get my cousin living there
I got my clothes we are laughing Walter
Barry was in there we were all having a
ball we wouldn't ever us laughing so my
back is turned ever but everybody's
laughing and all of a sudden everybody
stopped laughing and I'm talking stuff
yeah this [ __ ] ass [ __ ] man that [ __ ]
I'm waiting him I said I've turned my
Mitch greens in this [ __ ] he's
got a little scared oh [ __ ] Mitch
[ __ ] green then he started talking
what the [ __ ] you doing to my hood [ __ ]
oh then it was awesome then and you guys
you guys stood out in the street wearing
diapers in back street and it was quick
real quick
Papa talking about
he was just talking a lot and I'm I
really told you to grab him from my
pocket try to pull my pocket back cuz he
pulled my ripped my packet all the money
a fall but I won't have chance to get my
money after fight this cat right and
then my money to the wolves
so anyway that's why you started
punching him and it was over quick
yeah dropped him a couple of times but
he was high on AngelList so he kept
getting up right just like Friday the 13
the [ __ ] Mike Umayyads that guys talk
about this in your show right so when
I'm in the car now so I'm in the car I'm
tired
cuz I'm overweight a little bit I'm
fighting this gun I'm tired right I'm a
little drunk are you bugging that like
you dislike your the Heavyweight
Champion and like you're a dapper dance
like this is happening in the street
like are you like what the [ __ ] is going
on did you feel comfortable that I felt
comfortable doing about like [ __ ] I hurt
my hand in this [ __ ] but then I
mean I'm in the car he rushes to my car
breaking my Rosalie's he breaks the side
mirror pulling brakes and then um when I
Jimmy his [ __ ] was already frozen that
wasn't either his bleeding but he didn't
get he didn't have to rely Jami so I
went up to class excuse me woman I got
the car and I hit Mitch and Mitch went
down in the bindle when I grabbed his
head at him boom one time hit the
concrete boom oh then that's when he
without whom and I got scared didn't
move anymore when it's headed to
concrete and that's when I ran I ran
across the [ __ ] out of here I thought I
killed my so scared and right on 120
25th so what happened in the game the
paper also had Walter Barry was there
yeah Walter was still amerimike I feel
bad like the season I think what the
[ __ ] this [ __ ] up we did this
respectful [ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy yeah
this is a disrespectful [ __ ] you
had to see this [ __ ] you had no
idea I disrespectful this [ __ ]
you have to fight this guy in the street
he's gonna talk to you like a pig
infernal oh don't see how you ever see
I'm Harlan me that all of people walking
he's talking to you like a [ __ ] piece
of wretch in front of thousands of loud
laugh Jerry Hill mother [ __ ] that [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] homo [ __ ] dick sucking [ __ ]
oh he was one of the last l'ile ask the
last of last remaining people with a
jheri curl - now listen you don't sit
down I have nothing else in black you
could look like that that's gone all
right
they may have a little temperature in
the hair but no more the jheri curl
that's gone errors over the little man
this guy has rockin it yo but this is
what this is how interesting he is this
guy will rob the gas they just what he
would do so there's not enough money if
it's too early got there too early he
would tie the guy up hide them under the
gas station and start pumping the gas
and taking the money come in again mr.
green piece of [ __ ] yeah I'm I ran the
guard pump together they got the guy I
don't know that's [ __ ] funny Mitch
green is a [ __ ] character rap did you
start acting in New York LA I came out
to LA okay the reason why I came out to
LA this is a good Brownsville story so
in 88
before I had really figured out what I
was gonna do my friends now I was with
some at this point like I wasn't doing
anything but they're my friends I grew
up with them I had been with some dudes
that had been their rough dudes robbing
drug dealers you know they were they
were they were they were Brownsville
dudes daddy they but they for me they
were my guys this [ __ ] and and they
can't I went to college for one semester
at SUNY Old Westbury you probably went
up there bagged some chicks
Union I want the Union right so so so
they came out to my college and this is
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's all kids from
New York City so my god boy bear who
passed from Howard and my two other
friends they come on like you don't
don't start any [ __ ] cuz these are
literally dudes that were on some like
they'd walk past you what are you
looking at and if you didn't say nothing
they and I'm like you don't nothing with
anybody just everybody's cool here squat
go to school here but these were
literally all you can't take them out of
the neighborhood like they're on net
what are you looking at [ __ ]
if I was my friend suit you want to show
you friends a good time I made it come
check this out guys and then they
[ __ ] other new friends little white
friend Sheila [ __ ] out [ __ ] tease my
people man it's gonna be alright you you
must know that what you learn that [ __ ]
all the time I had to add the line I get
reprogram cuz of the reprogram me
because what are you looking literally
start so we're up it in [ __ ] on
Westbury there had been a couple little
like yo chill did literally like you
have to like like like like like a
pitbull Jill Jill Jill stop you know you
can't keep him off the leash these are
when I look back on so we made it for
was get ready we were getting ready to
leave we were getting ready to leave and
and we're coming out of some [ __ ]
like hallway or something like that
and these other two dudes like yo step
outside my man had just been in the
hospital I had gotten shot in Bravo that
little Brook they the Rob put the
building live real girl he had just gone
out he wasn't even healthy he had just
comes out there and and he's like he
still has stitches in a mother to guys
oh we're good they're like what are you
look
step outside something and the next
thing you know we're in a parking lot
and there's cars and the dividers in the
parking lots all have rocks that's how
they fill up you know the spaces so when
we step outside they're already out the
day start throwing rocks I'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on so this one kid me
him we're like fighting and [ __ ] we're
like tight tight tight up you know like
we're grabbing this [ __ ] like that and I
see his man and it's it's it's it's
either three on for two or four but they
were like step outside so we get outside
me and this dude like tied up with like
it's not like we're like fighting with
like tied up and I see the dude throwing
the rock come coming at me throwing a
rock and I leaned down like that and and
I I feel like boom and I knew it wasn't
a punch just the way the blood come man
I felt the blood coming down you see
this scar right here
I can dig this [ __ ] so so um dirt like
I'm like oh [ __ ] I grabbed the door well
I get him on top of a car now my weight
is fully on him right my weight is fully
on him
my arms are underneath him I can't get
my arms up his head is right here right
to my face this [ __ ] Mike bit my
[ __ ] ear when he's biting my [ __ ]
ear I go yo you're biting my [ __ ] ear
I looked as if he didn't notice [ __ ] I
feel like my ear like it goes numb I
pull off him I could feel blood coming
down here blood down coming down here no
one's punched me like it's just a
skirmish we get in the car yeah we try
to run these [ __ ] dudes over my
Browns will do to it just one of them
just kind of shot like I'm like my life
is over I can't feel my ear like to them
this is like a nothing yeah he's there
laughing these dudes are laughing like
yo son you're good bit my [ __ ] ear so
when Mike when you bit that
[ __ ] here I swear to God I had
a physical reaction I know no one else
I understood that [ __ ] like it was I
remember like so I had to get a skin
graph in my [ __ ] you know what's so
funny though but that was some Brit
that's what you get for hanging out with
Brownsville
yeah after that he said Brookdale I went
back to Brookdale Hospital they had to
put me and they left me there I'm
waiting wait this is like this is this
is 89 the [ __ ] service in Brooklyn is
something that it should be ashamed of
I'm laying there I'm waiting I'm waiting
I'm waiting I'm waiting by myself these
guys don't wait like you're good you're
gonna get a stitch here be fine and I'm
on the gurney you know cuz there cuz I
had that you know they cover me up and a
guy comes roll he had no shirt on he had
a [ __ ] huge rap around his head and
I'm like getting agitated like come on
when they could get me out of here when
are they getting me out of here the dude
next to me in the gurney he's like what
happened you I just I tell him a whole
story that I just told him I'm like 19
and my heart is racing I'm scared to
death all this [ __ ] he I tell him this
whole story like it's a big deal he's
talked to me got a whole rap on his head
he said I said what happened he said I
got shot in the head I was like well you
could go first yeah that's a real
[ __ ] story real [ __ ] story and
then I remember it and then this is when
when you said started acting in 1989 I
called my father told him what happened
told him who I was with and cuz I hadn't
called him all night he said I was
worried about you and I told him what
happened he so I'm glad your ID cuz I'm
getting to the point where I'm scared
the next phone call I'm gonna get is
dirt you got a bullet in you oh no and
that was the end of my that was I went
to Los Angeles a couple months later and
I was done cuz my father said that to me
I was like that's not happening to me so
tell me tell me Michael right hanging
around of people Browns and little
blacks and stuff right how do you how do
you how do you explain your family
because listen sometimes I have to
explain to people what they mean when
they call each other [ __ ] you know I
mean I have to explain to people what
the [ __ ] they mean if I'm with some
white people around go friendly and
thank you saying [ __ ] they get intense
right what do they mean why are they
calling each other [ __ ] Mike I said no
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] [ __ ] like person a
guy a girl a [ __ ] dude bro
whatever you have to explain it you know
it's using certain context you know you
got no one to use it I don't know if you
use it with the attitudes depending how
you use it you know smile when you say
in the hole some change it the way you
say it Martin for me Mom I remember my
for me to even explain to somebody it's
bugged out yeah it's like a it's like a
person a white Caucasian like a person
you know I mean that sounds crazy but
that's just what it like Browns that
I've had people explain big white
Caucasian [ __ ] where did this and that
yeah yeah uh when I was a kid I like
what the fur like I was just when you're
young you don't think so much but when
when my dudes used to be in my were kids
in Miami at my apartment I remember one
time we were watching a game [ __ ]
was me and my two friends and and this
and that and this and that's the rules
probably this big and this is because
we're kids these are two black kids and
me like we had grown up like that that's
how we spoke and and my father burst in
the door
I would are you guys saying whatever it
is I don't want any he was confused like
why and then and then [ __ ] him
in and you know he was like you guys
either stop or get the [ __ ] out of my
house and my father always remembered
that felt like being down south soon
with him he don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on my father was like amazing
Jewish teams and what the [ __ ] is season
seven where you get like you guys are
laughing it sounds like you having the
time of your life but yesterday but but
having it you know one of the things
that like now where we are and
everybody's like the peace eNOS and
people of color and and people you know
and and all this stuff that people have
one of the things that really bothers me
is that the the the over did like the
white guilt is at an all-time high and a
lot of to me the white guilt comes from
because some white people and some black
people we're both we're both guilty of
it but I'll just speak for my people go
for it they don't know physically know
intimately know any black people they
look at black people like there's this
foreign kind of people like they have to
be instead of like people are people and
there's some black people that
don't [ __ ] know intimately and I'm
saying not saying sucker I'm saying
intimately like they have any friendship
they've never been to a black person's
house and we don't know each other so
this is where these stereotypes and and
these dis dis dis stuff comes in and you
start looking at people like it's
something you see on Instagram or
something you see on blackish or
something you see or in a rap video or
something you see on the Real Housewives
because you don't know people and
there's [ __ ] up white people there's
[ __ ] up black people there's [ __ ] up
Jewish people that's [ __ ] up Chinese
people we're all foot we're all the same
and that's one of the things like cool
that I grew up like I know you know
being being exposed to black people
being exposed to [ __ ] in in in in 1560s
New York Avenue in the in the stairwell
like I'm like yo this is it does
something like you it just is what it is
and that's the blessing I got from
hanging around all that [ __ ] and you
know they do the cursors get in my ear
bit off ya [ __ ] bit my [ __ ] ear
mic can't we fight they're looping he
knows no ruthless to fight yeah that
caught me off guard that caught me
[ __ ] off guard that caught me [ __ ]
off guard your ear bit off in a fight
you have to understand listen we
frighten people in the street when
there's a possibility you might seem but
the possibility we never gonna see these
people again right so you don't want to
be the fact you ain't gonna see this guy
again and he left you with all this [ __ ]
and what is it over this is literally
over nothing no money no girls nothing
or so stump if you looked at me wrong
literally what are you looking at and
the next thing you know they're throwing
rocks and my [ __ ] ears bit and my
friends are like laughing at me and you
know heaven could have anything could
happen yeah I could agree respect is a
big thing in the hood yeah you know I
mean any hood black white oriental is
that such a big thing yeah how long we
been going we're rocking
we've been rocking you're gonna keep us
going for a while the you don't stop
strap you're the man dude listen
true romance man was that day with that
um hell deep blue sea [ __ ]
romance what the romance without a trip
they beat that girl a dilemma maybe
they're oh my god James Gandolfini Tony
Soprano yeah what was your first movie
this first one I did was a movie called
zebra head I remember that was that what
the [ __ ] you doing in a movie this is
real love don't hide the menu baby is
black and white layers you want it like
this baby did you know that girl in the
Boucher the actress you knew her
I've seen her around right off back in
the day she was very attractive yeah
this is what Mike was popping popping
popping around back in the day yeah yeah
I am Mike knew everybody
yeah that's pretty it's pretty fun um so
yeah that was my first movie Zebrahead
and then you know just been able to work
and and continue to work and now I you
know do my podcast and talk my shade and
continue to act and you know does he
ever go out there the bush girl I didn't
you something did you go out you never
know like the [ __ ] she's so hot and
stuff you know you know who you know she
was dating at the time when we were
doing the movie I remember she told me
this we were we were in the hotel room a
few of us but it at the time this is 91
92 but I remember she didn't say it
didn't say dating but I knew what she
meant
DeNiro and I was like oh so [ __ ]
lucky [ __ ] Bob De Niro was putting it in
yeah yeah so but I remember hearing that
[ __ ] I hadn't like hearing somebody that
even met Robert De Niro I was like what
the [ __ ] you knew you'd [ __ ] Robert
De Niro used to give her a hard time all
the time you use this like we see her at
the clubs and [ __ ] like that yeah it's
[ __ ] talking with this guy this big
dick with the Boucher yeah [ __ ] funny
me what's her name
Naboo she she's an actor she's still
around she's but she's a Brooklyn girl
pretty nice nice girl he's really
getting a [ __ ] nerve there with you
and my mama didn't I and I went through
this process I went to rehab and I
should make amends with everybody that
and I made a man hey are you serious
when you had to make amends the first
time did you have a long [ __ ] list my
man listen man I wasn't gonna do it
because the list was overwhelming I
wasn't gonna do cuz I I didn't released
those feelings I had with these few
these intense bad intentions I had with
these people it was hard all right and
some people some people had to make
amends but they were just regular people
at the time I didn't but I'm like am i
rehabbing so these people became
successful people and I said [ __ ] I'm
gonna get next to this person now so and
I find that one day I met them in the
elevator had two bodyguards and stuff
and I made my men that was a little
nervous cuz they're these [ __ ]
monsters around number seven and I hold
their hand and everybody looked up my
settings you know me I like to make
amends my life is different now and I
mean immense to them that's dope yeah
that's so awesome dude I mean mr. um I
still not finished you got a long
[ __ ] finish funny that's [ __ ]
funny Clements do these crazy I respect
that don't mind I I told you you know I
sometimes I have no respect for some of
these people don't you make amends for
yeah I have to make a man thing you know
how do you do that though oh hey listen
man you have to look at bigger than you
right and then we had to get all that
dirt out of you right I hear you
because I wouldn't have no respect from
I wouldn't continue harassing people
can't you do other stuff you ever done
DMT right what's that oh dude what the
[ __ ] is D I never even heard of DMT what
is that Tito DMT is like psychedelic
molecule I'm not [ __ ] with any of
that [ __ ] hell a [ __ ] no man
he'll [ __ ] no I'm not [ __ ] with no
there's some acid [ __ ] no it takes that
it's like a hundred times more so than
acid [ __ ] yeah Mike just smoked five Meo
DMT which comes from this toad it's a
toad venom Oh
see you guys are [ __ ] around on
another [ __ ] life did it really
I had a bunch of [ __ ] disgusting hope
I had cocaine had liquor I was about to
kill myself I was gonna die I know that
I was right dying stuff Oh Dean all the
time
is destroying myself and this [ __ ] this
[ __ ] like what did this [ __ ] do I don't
know what it did that's the whole thing
I don't know what the [ __ ] it did I just
I don't do that no more right I hear you
don't know what it did [ __ ] you [ __ ]
thought he was done everybody in this
[ __ ] place I got feel like everybody
in this whole Studios whacked out of
their [ __ ] tree the cameraman are you
guys [ __ ] whacked out of your [ __ ]
on that toad venom interesting guy
you're on that [ __ ] toad venom I had
talked to everybody out there these guys
everybody stoned out of their [ __ ]
minds [ __ ] died there on that good toad
venom ice guys [ __ ] it's true yeah I say
I can't no it's good stuff man it helps
I might look like addiction where do you
get it from you do with the shaman
shaman he gets it from Sonora Desert in
Mexico and he live in the ground like 10
months out of the year yeah all right
you can't take turns environment could
they won't be as potent listen I need to
be under doctor's supervision to do that
[ __ ] man I don't want to like but my
wife doesn't want anything to do with me
I'm sure she'd be like man [ __ ] no
listen it's just I'm just very grateful
at the opportunity to experience cuz all
my life
I thought I'm at that stage in my life
before I did the toilets and nobody can
tell me shipping all over the world
I dunno kind of good I made all kind of
great business days I've been wealthy
before I done it before that what do
these [ __ ] gonna tell me this
is common looking mother far what are
you gonna tell me I can tell you never
see this [ __ ] you guys so I experienced
it um it's never been the same
do you smoke it or is it like a smoker
yes putting in a pipe there's like a
crack pipe in your smoke Wow that toad
venom toad venom
I'm more ego number thing I'm a badass
[ __ ] on the planet [ __ ] you
[ __ ] no more [ __ ] to hold and all
that stuff it's just I don't know I hear
you all right what do you got some toad
venom here oh man wish we go yeah baby
what happened yes cold man since you're
smoking you just go to this um dimension
you if you can't it's inconceivable you
can't even explain it to people do you
know how long you were you were high for
on it 15 minutes and I thought it was
two hours three hours
Wow you [ __ ] with that toad venom hard
body right I could tell you but you
asked and DMT but not the five Emmy cuz
what I did was like the riverboat ride
this shit's like the space I hear you I
hear you know if I woulda knew myself
into if I didn't knew that I was gonna
feel that way about us or this on the
film advance before I'd that was never
took in it hmm pretty dope tonight maybe
I got a I got a I got AI got a running
up the flagpole what are you doing to
kids what do you have what kind of time
you spend with them well they're older
now my one sons in New York he's going
to colleges [ __ ] meet that boyfriend the
girl well I'm he didn't introduce you to
his girlfriend he but he I know it's but
yeah they're they're they're they're
young adult my girls don't bring their
friends to see me they'll bring their
dads your you're a word I mean even
though you're my tasting you got all
[ __ ] you got a [ __ ] New Balance so
you're just a dad right yeah and am i
shooting in a cool it off my kids
oh they must be servos [ __ ] I try to
tell that to my kids are like the New
Balance like now the New Balance they
wear them it's like ironic for them yeah
yeah yeah like you know that Mike's like
these are becoming hip with the kids cuz
it's like ironic like oh I'm I'm cool
but I'm wearing dad shoes yeah yeah them
stiff shit's Mike even you can't make
them [ __ ] school I'm sorry I know [ __ ]
so yeah but but my kid I see that
lighter my kids are the same way they
don't they don't want to walk really up
there yeah they're really good my
daughter is graduated from NYU
oh [ __ ] Mikey my son goes to the new
school it's like this it's like a
subsidiary of my you it's like art it's
more specifically based on the arts you
know like music and I don't yeah so but
it's it's right near and why you write
down there in the village no I'm Evan no
it's became no one's challenging I'm
paying two wishes a trip [ __ ] that's a
trip right you know didn't you really
know that your arm you're an adult when
you're giving all this money for someone
else
you know I'm say wow this is a lot of
money to be paying these kids you know
you realize the guy that I really want
them to go to school do they really want
to go to school you do they really want
to go like it's a no [ __ ] you're not
going to like just saying that this
ain't a trip to [ __ ] Palm Springs my
son who goes to American University in
DC but I don't know if you really wanted
to go to school you know and and the
reason why the reason why you start
asking that is because of the prices
yeah a hundred grand a year close 86 so
you start to go like [ __ ] I'm
paying for this you really like um yeah
[ __ ] yeah I'm pissed I'm paying for
something that I don't have to pay for
eighty six thousand dollars that's a
shitload of money no so if you're going
there does you're not going are those in
quarters [ __ ] isn't that the whole page
yeah yeah yeah it's fun just one yeah
that's one right school was a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] in high school
[ __ ] and you start to go like eh you
don't want to [ __ ] do this [ __ ] go to
public school yeah dude when I play for
the Bears so you know I played for the
Bears my daughter was in a [ __ ]
Montessori School in Chicago that was
like two grand a month to gran you'd be
lucky that paid for that now yeah lucky
to [ __ ] oh yeah I'm talking about
$35,000 for sixth grade I know the [ __ ]
dude this was preschool and they're
complaining about [ __ ] yeah 35 you
[ __ ] yeah I'm not making for $35,000
there's no more daddy can you make me a
sandwich
they need to figure out give you
something ravioli or something you know
um that's just that has a lot to do with
us anion securities when I get to have
the best part of year and then had the
best that we want them to have more
education of a better lifestyle than
what we had you know that's right that's
really what it is right reckless as we
were I agree you want to protect them
and all that [ __ ] but you start to win
its wind when it's 35,000 or college
like [ __ ] we're not this is
[ __ ] no I understand the joke to my
son as a joke to him and stuff you know
the stuff is the jokes and he didn't get
it yet
it's so crazy that that happens you know
when you're born into that right that
you don't realize
well took this [ __ ] guy came up you
know yeah I know it's so crazy oh yeah
like you what it took for you to
generate that life and then your kids
think it's just normal that's like the
normal they do life my kids don't have
enough black friends and they're black
yeah no I don't know black friends
well rap put you up to these days man
I'm all getting ready to start shooting
this Netflix show the third season
called atypical and I got the iron
Rapaport stereo podcast so tell me man
about this next flick everybody going
and next week they give it money away
huh they're giving money it's consistent
it keeps getting bigger and bigger and
it's changed TV and [ __ ] they it's like
a network it's like a network but it's
it's uh they changed their game changers
they [ __ ] change the game so they got
all kinds of [ __ ] original programming
and you know movies and it's Netflix's
dope you you watch Netflix yes yeah yeah
who doesn't staple that looks like it's
like it's like you know Nike Pepsi
Netflix ABC you might even say Netflix
before ABC or HBO yeah it's [ __ ] bid
ten years it's crazy it's crazy that
it's become it's of course I got Netflix
like the answer is of course I got no
don't if you don't write alien cuz
Netflix is dope yeah never [ __ ] dope
it is man Netflix and chill chill yeah
it's yeah so I'm just doing that so I'm
doing the podcast I am rapport stereo
podcast championship podcasts tell me
this what is it that you want to be your
crowning achievement what is it that you
want to achieve in this particular field
if I'm keeping it real keeping it real
my crowning achievement would be to to
write direct and act in a really good
movie whether whether it makes money or
be like if I know it's dope like if I
wrote directed and acted I would be like
that's that's pretty for as far as
artistry like acting you know like it's
not life that would be something I want
to do and
that's that that's the thing I'm like I
would I would be excited about to do
that [ __ ] which is not easy people you
know you see people do it pull it off
actors do it when they do that [ __ ] that
shit's if you write direct and act in
something and it's dope that's rare to
happen what the [ __ ] you think about so
you Mike what the [ __ ] you think my man
is solely like enlightened - I'm about
spike Lee winning the Oscar that
incredible I mean [ __ ] Mike
that's incredible was so happy I was
almost gonna cry for them oh it's
awesome yeah it was it was dope it was
dope seeing him do it and and and his
movies and you know I got harnessed I'm
gonna get it how I know how ping-mei
that he is yeah openly the way he talks
about these people and they got that
award and you know you you know Mike's
spikes sometimes I'm like yeah but but
Spike Lee Cree Spike Lee gave careers to
so many Rosie Perez John Turturro got
Danny Aiello his only Oscar nomination
made Denzel Washington a sex symbol mo
better blues Robin Harris the late great
Robin man yeah that's my guy had Robin
Samuel Jackson listen Robin never got
the praise they deserved uh but he was
the man oh man yeah he got me a life
he got Ray Allen so man you know so he
gave a lot of people you know he's been
we sort of you know he's been why gotta
have now the going to you know he's been
rockin so I'm glad he got the award and
uh you know he cuz he if anybody loves
and appreciates the business and the
culture of Academy Awards and
understands the history of it spike is
like he knows everything about this
business yeah the good the bad the
frustrating the movie business the
Academy Awards he knows all be seen
everything I [ __ ] like an
encyclopedia Google of film and cinema
so it's dope that he got it that's dope
he needs a Brooklyn dude
yeah man that's awesome you know and he
was one of the first people to like
bring you know like my path
Jay's Road is lighter thank you he was
one of the first people to like you know
you know have like shops in Brooklyn he
had the Spike Lee store and you know and
he was always talking about that you
know that Brooklyn [ __ ] in a different
way so so it you know Crooklyn Dodgers
feel so good to be a Crooklyn Dodger so
yeah [ __ ] up in here was that movie
you play with you higher learning you
were the [ __ ] do you turn into the
Nazi guy you can't started hanging with
the skinhead yeah it was dope you did a
good job thanks Mike
always mom you always do a good job man
oh [ __ ]
I learned it was dope Regina King was in
there she just won the Oscar - nice cute
she's dope cole hauser eat Jon directed
it omar epps it was originally gonna be
Tupac and Leonardo DiCaprio movie in
higher learning oh wow Tupac they
couldn't finance it they couldn't get
insurance cuz he had got locked up oh
well you know being a booking guy so
priority Brooklyn guys make it you know
I know what it's like no one makes that
know by the time they make it they love
so many people yeah I mean yeah yeah
well uh it's Brooklyn you live in New
York I'm back and forth okay you're here
in Los Angeles said no and New York I
know I don't [ __ ] with the winter I
don't have friends like I'm used to be
friendly to for a long time then when
you made it they took us over to bring
with them and you guys my friends
anymore kind of yeah it's tough yeah
because you know you want to help out
but then you can't you got you can't
abuse yourself you can't abuse yourself
that's what we do by doing that yeah uh
and I used to be overly generous and you
say oh well that's not a bad thing yeah
it is a bad thing if you're overly
generous and you're generous and and and
you know Mike I got a face like I think
is a disposition like that people think
like I got like a [ __ ] dumb looking
face like I just as part of my look like
my face is like kind of like you dumb
[ __ ] even if you you know me and and
sometimes I think people try to get over
on that and it you know relationships
for platonic relationships with you with
your boys we're guys they're not [ __ ]
easy either
like you think about how thick you know
like so being married to one person is
tough but like just being friends with
somebody for a long period of time yeah
you know it seems all good when you're
at the club and you're young and not you
but you know things happen people get
jealous people people [ __ ] you know
relationships are hard to keep you know
they're there work all of them you know
maintaining them staying in touch when
you get old you got kids you move oh I
haven't seen you in the menís one year
and I haven't seen you in two years
and and you know and then like real
tight people like success and money and
you know like [ __ ] all that I gotta take
care of myself I gotta take care of my
family I'm not taking care of like I'll
hook you up a couple of times but at a
certain point but sometimes you can't
it's hard enough sometime you can listen
them I'll give you a job but they'd only
want to work I'll give my job if they
want to work then they don't work and
then you got a farm so you're a double
[ __ ] yeah it's tough I just had some
[ __ ] with like over some money and
success and I'm just like interesting
you you you you you've been rocking with
me from day one and now you think you
think someone's like having a second
wife yeah no seriously I'm a second wife
yeah you're right you [ __ ] right
there's this partner and success and
money and it's not about like success
and money necessarily like famous people
just regular it happens at any level it
could just be anything it could just be
any [ __ ] thing it's ya know I just
went through it myself and a great
friend great guy but I got going with
this life now this is the new dimension
in my life we got to deal with it's
[ __ ] you know hmm
it's it's [ __ ] it support doesn't
have to be some dramatic fallout either
I just could Bisbee you know you'd say
sometimes it's drama sometimes it's just
I wouldn't just you know this ain't
happening right now you could come back
around who the [ __ ] knows life is short
who would you want to work with who's
your director you want to work good
Scorsese yeah Quinn Tarantino though
those are the guys that I talk to these
guys I'm trying to get
I'm working it's kinda you know it's the
right they know me I know them it's
gotta be the right thing at the right
time where they see it and I see it and
and it'll happen you know and it's so
Len I'm a [ __ ] fan oh I love those
[ __ ] Scorsese's my [ __ ] dude
yeah I've you know it just has always
well that's my fellas casino forget it
Raging Bull
all right dear oh my god Raging Bull is
so good Mike talk about Jake just as a
fighter because I know you you know all
this talk about Jake LaMotta yeah
determined fighter would determine fight
a very hard fighter beat strong-willed
determined hunt is hard to be as a
[ __ ] rock hard like hitting this
[ __ ] wall you know what I mean
had that low style yeah but he was he
didn't get hit as much people thought he
did everybody got hit more than he did
he was real smart you know
Sugar Ray Robinson they were beautiful
fights they would go at it oh they're
rivals a puncher versus oh like the
boxer versatile puncher right yeah but
they were punch each other out they
would go for it man dance drink fight
you know what I call I call myself -
Jake LaMotta podcaster
because you could because you know I say
I'm gonna take you 15 rounds into the
deal the deep water like Jake he's like
thank you the 15 like I'm the champion
for me I talk [ __ ] so I call myself the
[ __ ] did the champion of [ __ ] talking
and I'm gonna take you 15 rounds into
the deep waters the Jake LaMotta of
podcasting right that's one thing about
our leaders file he was so tough to beat
right cuz I believe this is one thing
you have to realize when you're going to
fight Ali the first thing yeah this is
just the first thing you sympathize you
have great boxing skills you punch all
you got great determination before all
that stuff you have to have a program in
your [ __ ] mind and in your heart I'm
going 15 rounds okay cuz I'm not
knocking this guy out that's it yeah you
gotta prepare to go 15 [ __ ] Russia
this guy's going nowhere nowhere no he's
gonna you better prepare to go 15 rounds
15:20 would Harlan [ __ ] yeah
y'all hate you then and box no
interesting when you lose them at the 15
and 20 round fight really the guy lost
some exhaustion can you imagine 20 [ __ ]
around awesome exhaust yeah 20 fun pick
your arms up 20 rounds of boxing with
bare knuckles and [ __ ] and this is what
I thought this I said well listen it was
20 40 rounds back then those guys
probably for in slow motion to keep
themselves just able to go to distance
and if I don't do one punch of 500
around he's got the fighting full
[ __ ] speed ahead 36 that's [ __ ]
crazy tremendous shape it's all
psychological they're in tremendous
shape unbelievable knockdown he gets
back up the fortieth rounds on bully
gets back down the 28th and he come back
and knock the guy down in the 40s round
5 that's some collar [ __ ] that's savage
[ __ ] I told you I started doing stand-up
comedy
when I was 19 but you know what it is
now because you you did the show even
though that but like you would riff off
sometimes we had unusual a sudden you I
never seen anyone do that cuz I seen you
do the show three times it's different
man do you understand who can mean
that's a different month that's it's a
different thing and I started back doing
it it's and so instrument as deep right
there you know you got expect to make
these guys laugh talking to yourself
right yeah come to laugh yeah at least
with a one-man show like it's a script
and you could always revert back to the
script and you could go well I can make
them laugh I can make them cry comedy
clubs they come for one reason to laugh
yeah they [ __ ] come out that's
like saying I'm gonna go to the tennis
that go to play tennis I'm going to play
tennis I'm going to the comedy club
I expect to laugh [ __ ] so that
depth that I keep that in consideration
when I'm up there [ __ ] around
sometimes because I'm like they paid to
see a show yeah and that coming some
some of these comedians really a bitter
kind of people
if they're there they [ __ ] they flunk
before and every people boo and yes
before they always gotta be on top of
their game and imagine like you said
being a person who's talking to
themselves like that's their psyche
that's why comedians are [ __ ] weirdos
in real life have been kind of dog yeah
a dark and and and narcissistic and you
know so so I like it I'd be not this is
God for this kind of game like any kind
of competition like football yet that
that belief that your God kind of you
know I mean you know is another thing
Mike I just wanted to throw this out you
talked about the podcast I I said this
last week I said on the on the I am rap
for stereo pockets I was in the middle
of some some [ __ ] with some [ __ ] talking
I said my taste is impeccable my style
is impregnable and I said a shout-out to
the great Mike Tyson oh yeah I said that
but legging my [ __ ] talk and I was like
my taste is impeccable
my style is impregnable Oh shout-out to
the great Mike Tyson oh yeah
so that I use my boxing references in my
[ __ ] just because although I've never by
sparred one you're not Danny Jacob yes
yeah the good guy what do you think I'm
gonna do against um Alvarez Tinnell I
mean what do you think could be a good
fighter be tough for me or who do you
think like if you had like who would you
say is gonna win [ __ ] I would like Danny
to win you know I mean it's gonna be a
tough fight for ya
Canelo's a [ __ ] do you [ __ ] with
any boxers at all like like in terms of
like like do you do work with like you
have anything to do a box in our like or
fighters not that much really no more
if a young fighter that was like like a
real boxer was like a Mike I wanted to
come in and and see if you could help me
you know do the body movement would you
work with a fighter that like like would
you do that for the love for the money
or if the person asks you like I want to
help like the headsman listen if I had
the time I'll do it for free for the
love yeah if you respect and I love
early it's really helped the guy right
hope the guys can if it was somebody
that you thought was worthy of it I
don't have to think he's worthy if they
asked me to do it that's dope you know
that's down the sensei sensei Mike
wasn't that great I was thinking about
like I can't believe the box before and
your style was [ __ ] ill it was weird
that was just weird doing this stuff
vicious ma'am but the the the the body
movement yeah the legs is [ __ ] like is
your back good my back is it from is it
from this yeah my back of my neck my
neck held my football never do it some
prehistoric like old schools like I did
with the [ __ ] strap in the way yeah
yeah the neck now they got you across
like that and Wow yeah [ __ ] brother
let's wrap this thing yo are you ready
yeah you ready brother how we do it how
do we do it rap thanks man
hey do you want anybody - awesome
brother area pockets Mike I said to see
before you've been a part of my life I'm
such a fan and and the thing I told this
and I wrote about it in my book I said
you know you know and I know you I know
you're working progress like all of us
but it humbled me watching you come to
the other side of who you are today
because you know I go around my big
mouth and I'm a fake fake fake tough guy
and and when going seeing you go through
your stuff and we're New Balance and I'm
just using that as a as a sort of
symbolism but for you to be humbled and
chill and on the other it's something I
think about when I start to think that
I'm invincible you know and that you
have to grow up and that you you have to
let your guard down and you know let the
young kids let the young kids rule
essentially and you know be a good
person
a decent person and and and I respect
that so much Michael and I'm doing my
best man but that's what you mean you
hung out with Jocko in those guys those
guys look these guys are like legends in
my neighborhood they take all the kids
that have telling them stuff and they're
helping it to the pros and they guide
them and these are all some role models
in our community you know in our
community there's a lot of guys I think
they're badass you know got a spare
everybody respect Jocko everybody
respected him
so anyway I'm from brown film for that
to respect people if you just wanna kill
you they don't give a [ __ ]
mmm Jaco had a deep respect cause
everybody was a good man
they knew that [ __ ] he was a coop at the
Brownsville Recreation Center the BRC
shoutout to Jocko yeah Greg Jackson
former New York Knick Brenda Leigh who
the player - oh yeah dude I'm [ __ ] Mike
awesome episode brother any time I'm so
happy you guys are doing this and I
can't wait to see uh what's next for you
guys and and this was this is my
pleasure Thank You Burke thank you great
episode yeah brothers and sisters man I
got a brother
yeah and a sister older younger older
different but similar hey I can dig it
definitely is a holder the right show
all right you guys
we're out of here Mike peace
[Music]